what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight update video some interesting
photos have been surfacing online ever
since the majority of the cast has
started to show up in Northern Ireland
to prepare to film the eighth and final
season of Game of Thrones this isn't
breaking news because these photos did
come out the other day but I haven't had
the time to make a video yet because
I've been very busy but hopefully this
will get some of you excited at least a
little bit before I get into the photos
I just want to let everyone know that
the next winner of my Game of Thrones
series giveaway has been randomly
selected and I will announce your name
at the end of this video you can still
enter the giveaway if you use the link
that's down in the description I still
have several seasons of The Game of
Thrones series left that I am giving
away but let's get started like I said
at the beginning of this video most of
the cast members have started to show up
in Belfast because filming is starting
this month so we should see more and
more photos leaking by the day and as
filming begins these photos should start
to reveal some of the things we can
expect to see in the final season
everyone pretty much knows which
characters we are guaranteed to see in
the final season because there are
important characters which the main
storyline relies on being there but
there are still a handful of characters
that we haven't seen in a while that
could show up in this last season so
they can at least tie up those loose
ends but there are also a few characters
like torment and beric who are left
hanging at the end of season 7 when the
wall came crashing down and they kind of
left it up to the audience to decide
whether they survived or not when the
night king and Viserion brought down the
wall while they were standing on top of
it some of the fans said torment and
barrack died while other fans said
torment and barrack ran through the
other side of the wall before it fell
down well with the recent photos that
came out I think that rumor can be put
to rest because tormund Giantsbane has
arrived in Belfast which means he will
be in season 8 but just to be fair I
guess he could always play a dead body
at the beginning of the season one of
the first scenes in season 8 could be at
the wall as they show the aftermath of
Eastwatch being completely destroyed
they could always show torment and
barracks dead body laying there
somewhere where Eastwatch used to be but
if you look at who is standing next to
torment that could reveal another big
clue about what to expect in season 8
torment is actually standing to lore
commander ed and this could mean torment
and Ed has some scenes together in
season 8 which might explain why they
are hanging out together because
rehearsals are starting this week I'm
not sure if torment and barek are gonna
be able to climb down the wall now but
they could walk along the top of the
wall and go to Castle black which is
right in the middle of the wall and
that's where they could get to the
bottom of the wall and meet with Lord
Commander and
Richard dormer who is beric Dondarrion
was also seen in Belfast this week too
but they didn't all get a photo of him
but he is in Belfast while most of the
cast is in town too which is a pretty
good sign barrack we'll be filming some
scenes in the final season also now
there is one thing to remember the wall
actually has 19 castles along the entire
wall and even though most of those
castles are out of commission torment
and barrack may be able to get down to
the bottom of the wall in any of those
castles as long as they aren't in too
bad of shape either but the worst case
scenario torment American walk along the
top of the wall until they get to Castle
black and that's where they could
regroup with that and the rest of the
men there and hopefully they can assist
John in some way I was very relieved
when I heard torment was being sighted
around Belfast this week because he is
one of my favorite characters and I was
hoping he didn't die when the wall came
crashing down I wasn't entirely
convinced he died but you never really
know who they're gonna bring back for
the last season with only six episodes
to go but torment needs to have a better
ending than that
I think torment needs to see Brienne at
least one last time before he dies in a
blaze of glory I was also happy to see
that he was with that as well because he
was really only in one quick scene in
season 7 when he let brain and mirror
come through the wall they can't let
Lord Commander out of Castle black go
out like that either we're gonna need to
see some closure with these secondary
characters even if they died during the
Great War but I would like to see John
and Ed reunite one last time before it's
all said and done there are still
several other characters remaining in
this story that haven't had any real
closure yet and I'm not really sure if
we're ever gonna see them again or not
that little [ __ ] Robin Arryn hasn't been
seen in a while and it's hard to say if
we're ever gonna see him again
and miR Tolly is still out there
somewhere too of course and the same
snakes are still locked up in his cells
now tyene is most likely dead by now but
a Laureus sayin should still be alive do
you think we're going to get another sea
with her or even Robin let me know what
you think down in the comments I am
gonna keep this video very short and
sweet though I just wanted to give you
that main update because I thought that
was pretty significant news but make
sure you keep your eyes open for any of
my new videos because filming is just
now beginning and more photos will be
coming out from all the various sets
that they're gonna be filming at I'm
sure the spoilers are gonna be coming
out strong any day now just a quick
reminder I will be live-streaming this
Friday for all of my patreon supporters
that should begin right around 8 p.m.
Eastern Standard Time and if you would
like to watch the live stream and have
your questions answered my patreon link
will be done in the description also but
now it's time to announce the next
winner of the giveaway today's winner is
Christian from Vancouver Canada
congratulations Christian just make sure
you send me a private message on here or
you can email me and let me know which
game of Thrones season you want good
luck to everybody else and thank you all
for watching I really do appreciate that
have a great day and I will see you in
the next one bye
[Music]
you
[Music]
you